[Music]
there is a correlation with our active
monsoon season and kids being seen at
the local pediatrician's office and with
kids and teens now back in school
pediatricians offices seeing children
for a variety of reasons
we just received our flu vaccine
probably two weeks ago dr kerry weejay
singha medical director of siena
pediatrics treating kids right now for
the rhinovirus which is the common cold
rsv infections as well as the flu i'm
getting reports from my specialists that
they're seeing influenza a little bit
too so already so it's yes and they
think that just because maybe school
starts earlier that maybe that's
bringing this stuff in as earlier as
well the flu vaccine recommended for
children six months and older the
american academy of pediatrics says
vaccines are the best way to prevent
severe illness and keep kids in the
classroom we had a very active monsoon
season and so things are growing
longer than we expected and so people
are having more allergies the past few
weeks dr weijie singha saw a sharp rise
in kids wheezing from viruses as well as
allergens children are sometimes
presenting with asthma symptoms one in
13 americans has asthma and typically
children start developing it during
childhood when their immune system is
still advancing certain triggers such as
viruses environmental factors like
cigarette or vape smoke as well as
pollution can increase the risk of
asthma in addition to the genetics or
family histories of allergens or eczema
we do have our pulmonologists our
allergists they are the ones testing
that as well so a lot of times we see a
pattern we're referring these kids to
our specialists as well too
there is no cure for asthma but your
pediatrician can help you recognize
individual triggers provide medication
to help control the symptoms and adjust
your treatment plan as you age